je rappelle que les services d'ouverture
en dehors des stades c'est une fois tous
les 3500 ans puisque ça n'a jamais
existé donc effectivement on peut
imaginer que à situation exceptionnelle
moyen exceptionnelle
[Musique]
transformer les citoyens puis tous les
touristes qui vont participer aux JO en
cobaye bon alors certes Google l'avait
déjà fait d'utiliser les données sans le
consentement des personnes tout ça mais
on s'attendait pas à ce que la patrie
des Lumières le pays de la Déclaration
des droits de l'homme soit celui qui
promet et qui fasse passer à l'intérieur
et qui fasse passer par le Parlement une
loi qui propose de transformer en cobaye
et l'intégralité de la population qui
sera sur le territoire français ce que
vous proposez donc à travers cet article
7 c'est de faire en sorte d'avoir un
traitement biométrique généralisé à
l'intégralité de la population qui
passera de vendre ses caméras c'est une
dérive gravissime de ce que autorise
notre droit et ce qui est dramatique
c'est que vous vous cachez derrière
l'expression la reconnaissance faciale
sera interdite pour cacher le fait que
les données sur les visages elles seront
traitées par l'intégralité des
algorithmes le Parlement au plus tard le
31 décembre un rapport d'évaluation le
rapport d'évaluation est transmis à la
CNIL l'évaluation associe deux députés
de sénateurs donc y compris le position
respectivement désigné par les
présidents d'assemblée nationale et du
Sénat dont au moins un député un
sénateur de l'opposition et le rapport
est publié ça fait donc 28 garanties ça
n'a pas de précédent alors je comprends
que je comprends que peut-être que Nina
loi
je comprends que
je comprends que ni la loi de la
République ni le gouvernement ne peut
peut-être vous convaincre peut-être
oserais-je vous citer le rapport
lui-même de la CNIL vous citez la CNIL à
tout moment là vous l'avez pas cité des
libération numéro
202218 du 8 décembre 2022 qui fait une
vingtaine de pages
valide intégralement la proposition du
gouvernement et je voudrais vous
renvoyer à sa page numéro 9 et même sans
considérant 35 la Commission souligne
que l'encadrement des vêtements
algorithmiques créés par le projet de
loi prend en compte une large partie de
ces recommandations après tous ces
arguments du Conseil d'État de la CNIL
et la loi Jean vient à me dire que
finalement ce n'est pas tellement la
bonne orientation des Jeux Olympiques
qui vous intéressent mais une position
je crois assez stérile
[Musique]
on vous suspecte de vouloir après le 1er
janvier 2025 de vouloir continuer le
dispositif et de le mettre en place
définitivement en disant regardez
c'était vachement bien en tout cas ça a
fait de temps à personne donc il faut le
déployer parce que sur le terrain tout
le monde nous dit que ça marche parce
que l'important la phrase clé c'est sur
le terrain tout le monde nous dit que ça
marche d'ailleurs peu importe l'étude ça
marche donc il faut le pérenniser le
groupe démocrate votre a cet article 7
effectivement nous avons un besoin de
protection des jeux et ce besoin de
protection et d'autant plus important
que nous allons accueillir des touristes
des athlètes qui nous le demandent et
qui nous demandent cette protection et
nous avons besoin que nous puissions
avoir de l'aide de que les algorithmes
puissent aider les forces de l'ordre à
pousser des situations sur lesquelles il
y aura un traitement humain et une
décision humaine il n'y a aucune
décision automatique et il n'y aura
aucune reconnaissance faciale à aucune
biométrie